a perda foi a companhia de bar é seu
direito de voto até o fim da barra e
roupa lavada do ego
alega que para subir a chuva airbag chun
gaúcho 2011 o shopping voltou ao tj coca
cola
a equipe gaúcha vai ficar acho um jovem
piloto campeão da época é mau e ai
galera com seu canal quando você entra
quem mais o hotel e aparecendo muito meu
quarto eu deixei igualzinho harangody
meu quarto eu também oi galera aqui em
são luís em fazer um show aqui tem
vários shows também em joão pessoa no
teatro pedra do reino é gigante ataque
que você precisa saber para comprar
ingresso e isso tem show em belo
horizonte também no lugar imenso que é
muitos ingressos que tem à venda não
queria passar vergonha na cidade do jogo
não comprou ingresso e esse dia eu fui
assistir um menino meu nome todo mundo
pedindo pra assistir porque a foto
estava a assistir o filme todo o estado
não sei se o wii se suicidou pêra e
assim não é então fui lá no cinema
assistir esquadrão suicida chega e
cinema pata último filme estourada tinha
acabado de assistir legendado porque a
voz a turnê já cheguei lá tinha
derrotado a legenda tio do lado b leza
situada 165 dublado foi assistir ao
filme começando um presídio o filme
começa mostrando cada presidiário o
primeiro monstro smith que é um cara que
atira nunca é relativa à cabeça que ele
quiser pode ficar fora o cara tira
popular mas eu sei que o cara perde um
botão aqui dá um tiro na cabeça do cara
lá embaixo não me era difícil trocar
tiros para sofrer e se arrastado agora
não quero dar um tiro no piauí matou em
rondônia michiko na mira bubu e é bom
ter uma cena que chegam muito policial
no monstra tipo mostra grande não mostra
a cara torta o negócio é simone regina
casé é aí vem um monte efe os 40
policial
aquele mais com medo pra tá tá tá que
bubba smith vai sozinho ontem na cabeça
ei ei pega na rua parando ei ei acabou
especial do tipo assim macacos me mordam
esse cara é muito bom há há há eu sou
melhor gostar da esquina que aquela
moedas coisa bonita estatal é maluca é
doido ea morte por um só aspecto essa
lei quina ela é doida é o coringa é
ligado o curinga hora e ele o curinga
chamou ficar vivem perigosamente tipo
pega o carro entrou na contramão e ficar
a sbb carnaval e em 11 mil em dinheiro
eles adoram viver assim o perigo chega o
batman perseguindo esse carrinho e
depois apanham em vez de correr se
escondendo não fica só apanha depois de
aquele cara que faz vídeo falando mal de
policial olha o policial chega aqui no
bairro e não para matar alegando que
precisa para matar num local público que
aqui não pega lá fora vai matar olha
polícia pega meta o [ __ ] manda fazer o
vídeo fala fala fala e agora fala
gravada ok primeiramente aí pedi
desculpa e tal como negócio que eu falei
do policial e também a oficial é tudo
gente boa também aponta a gente é
acontece comigo série harry potter vídeo
com a polícia a apanha apanha apanha
apanha muito ó fala que o certo é que
fala que tem que estudar vala onde cai
todo mundo a estudar para a instituição
começa a estudar nela até o bruxo também
chamada magia e quem faz é a cara de
londrina essa mulher que esse cara de
bruxa caderno brochura de verdade é que
tinha brunch com na área do castanharo
com vergonha na cara cabelo branco pele
ruim deus caldeirão com bosta de cavalo
asa de morcego perde gaal dizer coisas
como essa vêm sendo bruxa todo mundo
queria ser harry potter harry potter da
província todo o hype pode saber o que
fazer muito bem o meu papel de trouxa
essa bruxa muito mas é [ __ ] é tipo assim
buscam o ônibus pra mim né
aparece uma busca um arquivo guardado
pra mim num cofre secreto em amsterdã
nenê aparece um arquivo da música pra
mim a virgindade da xuxa ela não
consegue que tem certas coisas que só
jesus merece o meu nome lá gato o
lagartixa sei lá o diabo um calango onde
de fogo que solta fogo a galera no filme
o filho também tem aqueles policial que
se acha que sabe tudo policial que se
acha como rosquinha e odiado filme eu
fui comprar não tinha legendado só tinha
doado por muita procura e todo mundo
gosta legendado que a legenda é mais
daquela emoção de escutar a voz do ator
legendado que tipo assim ok o meia mário
fofoca sangue do lado fico assim vá se
dá na cara seu filho da mãe bastardo
para todo mundo for alérgica mesmo
momento que ela saiba tirar seu canalha
é 2 armas armas vida real a diferença
pegou a bandeira pega pré mirim não sabe
a mata urubu todo mundo é [ __ ] um atira
pra carai a outra tira também outro
solta fogo é um lagarto lagarto possui
por exemplo paga tiver cheio de
borboleta e como já ajuda mas todo mundo
é [ __ ] e aí os caras do governo tipos
policial quer usar todos esses caras
poderosos como arma tempos ea arma do
governo junto não dar certo uma bumbum
tipo aquelas pessoas que fala todo o
plano que vai acontecer e faz uma cena
vamos usá-los como arma e vocês serão do
governo seremos a maior potência mundial
há há há há há aí morre bom que a bruxa
cara dela venha lá ela vai ter mais
poder do que todo mundo pensa ela vai
chamar o irmão dela evoca o satanás mega
todo o filme tem um satanás é com a
cesta no filme um satanás se bem que o
cavaleiro televisão de madrugada tem uns
oito demônio assim a galera assistir de
boi então tem o filme eles mandam esse
pessoal os poderosos para tentar
destruir a mulher que tem poder demais
só que todo mundo já sabe que não vai
dar certo porque a mulher tem poder
demais e oscar entendem por isso que
chama esquadrão suicida isso é quase
impossível se formos para isso estamos
indo direto para a morte eu não eu não é
claro que você vai você é doida haitham
até o corpo de aparelho decalcado do teu
filho foi criado o vento me esperando em
casa e aí todo mundo se este coragem vai
comissão são coisas que você tem que
assistir para saber se você tiver gostar
desse vídeo seja sabe que gostei aqui no
youtube volta lá no facebook eu fiz um
post lá vídeo nó
4 600 que ela clique em curtir no
facebook marck seus amigos que já
assistiram o filme com a marca que ele
sabe que espero que o fato do filme la
comenta aqui embaixo no youtube se você
assistir o filme que você gostou do
filme o que você não gostou do filme eu
particularmente achei o filme [ __ ] assim
de efeitos especiais tal mas acho que a
história do filme poderia ficar um pouco
mas eu não sou nenhum roubar dinheiro
rodrigo santoro wagner moura eu sou
ninguém para dizer mas acho que a
história poderia ser trocado porque uma
massa maior de efeito especial por fora
não cometem mais que você achou isso aí
valeu um castigo veio até aqui é nóis
iberê e porque o partido verde